[Music]
when i look deeply into it
it seems somehow another world from
which there is no return
not only for those whose bodies are
buried but perhaps for no one
to do justice to this other world a new
speech would have to be born
we would have to learn it you would
never understand it
this is what makes it so difficult to
write
more and more we are to be counted among
the dead among the estranged
because the greatness of the occurrence
estranges
and separates us
the morning came saddle mount walk
march towards the enemy
a baptism of fire for three days of all
sorts
we are up against english and french
troops a very tough fight because
although
we outnumber them we are hampered by the
lack of planes
so the gun positions of the enemy cannot
be spotted and we have to endure their
fire
without replying to it our army has ipra
as its objective
there is no doubt that the english and
french troops would have already been
beaten by trained troops
but these young fellows we have only
just trained
are too helpless particularly when their
officers have been killed
the fact that the enemy is near makes
the villagers dangerous as well
i was fired on quite unpleasantly from
some houses the prescribed procedure and
this event to burn the houses in
question
is nonsense increasing the confusion and
the resistance
that almost always strikes the innocent
i had two men shot whom i found in two
houses from which we were fired on
this had the required effect
[Music]
the battle continues fierce night
encounters
a grandiose horizon of burning clouds
like sections of agate
we halted for some time dismounted along
a wall
the whole squadron on the other side of
the street there was a little wayside
chapel such as our common in this part
of the country
empty and unused my trumpeter asked
whether he should take the horses inside
his and mine evidently thinking that
they would be safer there
first i said yes then for some reason or
other
no so he stood outside with the horses
in a few minutes a heavy english
shrapnel shell broke through the back of
the shrine
and burst in the middle
if the trumpeter and i had been in the
chapel there would have been nothing
left of us
all the horses only one ball got the
trumpeter's unfortunate horse and killed
it
the trumpeter looked at me strangely as
if i were the lord god
[Music]
this video was sponsored by the great
courses plus the premier online learning
service
anything you need to know about the
great courses plus has a university
quality lecture on it
one great example that was very useful
for this video was the long
19th century european history from 1789
to 1917
a fascinating dive into the turbulent
century that led up to the terrible
conflict
of the great war and it was as simple as
searching for the thing i needed
fascinating university level stuff all
that a very reasonable subscription for
what is essentially a mountain of easily
digestible knowledge
i can't recommend it highly enough
so check them out at
thegreatcoursesplus.com
forward slash voices to get a free trial
and show your support for the channel
too
i started with a free trial and never
look back
thanks
slow progress if it can be called
progress
naturally the smaller success is noted
with satisfaction but a setback is not
shouted from the housetops already the
place has become a waste
fire and death are everywhere empty
plundered farms graves with a helmet
stuck on them
the mounds often built up with the hands
out of the solid clammy clay
the wounded often lie for days for
fighting goes on to and fro by night as
well as by day
of course there is still oats for the
horses in the farmhouses
but precious little for the men we have
no oil for the lamps no light
no salt no bread the dragoons managed to
make a potato soup
it was delicious because we were so
hungry our fight infantry battalion
almost all marburg students
the best troops we have as regards
musketry have suffered terribly from
enemy shell fire
in the next division just such young
souls the intellectual flower of germany
went singing into an attack on
langermark
just as vain and just as costly
[Music]
everything on the front is rooted to the
same spot
i don't call it a success when a trench
a few hundred prisoners are taken
they've always cost more blood than they
are worth the war has got stuck into a
gigantic
siege on both sides the whole front is
one endless fortified trench
neither side has the force to make a
decisive push
behind us the peasants wander slowly
back to their farms so far as they are
still standing
but there is no return to passchendale
the ruin here is indescribable
the houses are torn from top to bottom
they overhang they are still falling in
the paving of the streets is in the
houses the roads are pitted with the
craters of burst shells
roofs lie in the street cobblestones lie
in the bed with the window sashes they
brought in with them
a lake of beer has flowed from the
broken vats of the brewery into the
cellars
one can see it through a sieve of arches
not a pillar in the church is unbroken i
saw the tower fall in one piece across
the marketplace
a great bloated cloud of yellow dust
arose from the marketplace as if the
dust itself
bore a banner in our living room was a
dead horse
with half its entrails trailing over the
yellow silk chairs and cushions
i cannot guess how it got there
everyone is getting ready for a winter
campaign as far as i can judge there is
no possibility of an early finish
the problems of the end are too great
for that
even though the situation is favorable
on the whole as it seems
one gets fed up with the length of the
operations
the troops are getting naturally more
undisciplined than they were after their
training
the senselessness and greed of the
people around the transport and field
kitchens which are more attractive than
the places where there is shooting
is already perfectly disgusting
unfortunately
everyone does not seem to be possessed
of patience the corps and army
commanders
see that the others in other parts have
obtained tangible successes
so they thirst for laurels too it is a
human
weakness but they think it is a virtue
not to lag behind the others
and do not realize that this virtue must
be paid for
in blood cold storms
snowflakes that make the horses shake
their heads with annoyance
warn us that we must get ready for cold
weather today for the first time it is
quieter on the front
the trenches filled with icy water do
not encourage one to reinforce the
slender garrisons with which both friend
and foe are holding the fire
both parties are in the same situation
the business may last for a long time
we have now been stuck in the same spot
for five weeks
for five weeks the newspapers have been
saying that epri has to be the decision
of this phase of the war
at least this may have been right a few
weeks ago
but the decision depends also on the
time taken to affect it
now this part of the front is losing the
character of a decisive sector
what we have gained in ground and the
enemy's losses however great
can only be called a success by a man
who does not see both sides
four apart from the fact that our losses
have probably balanced those of the
enemy
no one can possibly estimate at present
what this breathing space of five weeks
may mean for france and england
we may be stuck for good and all
now the losses are often the fault of
the men how men do not trouble their
heads over the fact that only picked
snipers are firing from the enemy lines
men who at a ranger often less than 100
yards cannot help hitting every head
that shows itself
it is not contempt of death that makes
them expose themselves to certain death
it is a lack of discipline precise
instructions and orders on the subject
have been drawn up but they are not
observed one officer said the other day
by way of excuse
that it was exactly the same in 1870
i replied all the worse
as matters stand now not only here but
all along the line
both we and the enemy have so crippled
ourselves by infighting
that we cannot get a blow in properly we
cannot get the momentum for a thrust
once again i observe that here at least
the art of war
is not noticeable it may be an
incredible achievement to create this
endless unbroken line from the alps to
the sea as a monstrous whole
but it is not my idea of a strategy
not one of the belligerent powers and
not one of their men
have as yet developed a technique of
modern
warfare to impress one's particular
stamp on a war napoleonic hannibalic
mulkey-esque or caesarean but whose
style have we to show
in the west our first advance had a
style that could be perceived
but it seems probable that it was
conceived and planned by one who is now
dead or who is not on the spot to carry
on the style
winter quarters is written plainly now
all units except those in the very front
line
are bringing up their second line
transport of course this shows how safe
we feel ourselves we would not dare to
do it otherwise
but it shows also that we have renounced
our freedom of maneuver
and therefore that we expect a long
period of stagnation
it will be indeed a strange christmas
that is coming
perhaps the great justification of
celebrating this feast of peace in
wartime at all
will not occur insuperable
contradictions seem to me like
changing dreams at night the year is
drawing to its close
it has been a grave year for all of us
who in spite of all earnestness and deep
thought
must admit to ourselves that we cannot
realize
what the war means does it not seem to
be a
monstrous folly that mankind with drawn
sword is weltering in a massacre
before which it will someday stand agast
like ayax among the slaughtered sheep
i have not written to you for a long
time but i have
thought of you all the more as a silent
creditor
but when one owes letters one suffers
from them so to speak
at the same time so it is with the war
feeling deeply about it one becomes less
able to talk about it
every day not because one understands it
less each day but because one
grasps it better but
it is a silent teacher and he who learns
becomes silent too
the stagnation that this siege warfare
has brought about gives a superficial
observer the illusion of peace
one regulates intercourse with the local
population as well as one can
one tries to arrange for the tillage of
the land one trains the men as well as
possible in mud and filth
one visits the officers of neighbouring
units one spends hours
in discussion the war is ignored
for not everyone has the capacity or the
habit to notice it in everything and
everyone
yet it is behind everything and everyone
that is the strange part of it the
starlings that winter hear abouts in
hordes
whistle like rifle bullets and as the
bullets cannot have learned to whistle
from the starlings
one may safely presume the opposite
and everything whistles its tune of the
war the houses
the fields men beasts rivers and even
the sky
the very milk turns sour under the
thunder of shell fire
what the english do they do well they
will make good soldiers
perhaps not so many as people think but
good ones if england were to introduce
conscription
it would be more dangerous for us than
anything she's ever done
the quality of troops has always
compensated for their comparatively
small numbers
they have given us plenty of trouble
here few though they are
in fact definitely outnumbered they say
that ipra must fall now
one can see it burning not without a
pang for this beautiful city
langermark is a heap of rubbish and all
rubbish heaps look alike
there is no sense in describing one
all that remains of the church is the
doorway
with the date 1620
the battlefield is fearful one is
overcome by a peculiar
sour heavy and penetrating smell of
corpses
rising over a plank bridge you find that
its middle is supported only by the body
of a long dead horse men that were
killed last october lie half in swamp
and half in the yellow sprouting beet
fields
the legs of an englishman still encased
in putties
stick out into a trench the corpse being
built into the parapet
a soldier hangs his rifle on them
a little brook runs through the trench
and everyone uses the water for drinking
and washing
it's the only water they have nobody
mines the pale englishman
who was rotting away a few steps further
up
in langermark's cemetery a hecka tomb
had been piled up
for the dead must have laying above
ground level
german shells falling into it started a
horrible
resurrection at one point i saw 22 dead
horses
still harnessed accompanied by a few
dead drivers
cattle and pigs lie about half rotten
broken trees drives rays to the ground
crater
upon crater in the roads and in the
fields
such is a six-month-old battlefield
[Music]
you